-My next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress.
Her new series, "Physical,"
premieres June 18th
on Apple TV Plus.
Here is Rose Byrne!
Yeah!
Oh, I'm so happy to see you.
-Hey, man!
Oh, my God!
You're back in the studio!
-I'm in the studio. I'm back.
We have an audience.
We have a full audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is -- Thank you, buddy.
You know, you did our show
when we were doing our show
from my home,
and I really appreciate you
doing that, you and Bobby.
That was really awesome.
I appreciate that.
You're the best.
-So good to see you back there.
-You're in Australia.
Is that correct?
-I think so, yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-It's early.
I got up really early, so --
But you guys are --
It's like late night there.
It's a big -- You're having fun.
-Yeah. This is New York
at nighttime,
and that's Australia at daytime
is where you are.
-Wait, I'm in the future.
I'm in the future.
-You were born and raised
there in Australia.
How does Bobby take
going to Australia?
He's New York.
New Jersey? Where is he --
-Yeah, he's from Jersey
via, you know, Florida,
Puerto Rico, you know, but he --
He's great, you know?
He's such a champ.
He loves Australia.
It's a beautiful country
and a great city.
He just --
He can't get down with Vegemite,
so that's been, like,
a bit of a issue.
-Yeah, Vegemite is a thing,
yeah. I mean, I --
I've never had it.
Hugh Jackman actually came on
and made it
the right way for me,
because I've tried it on dares,
and I just do it wrong.
What is the -- What's the key?
'Cause it does --
Sometimes it just tastes
like, well, poison maybe.
[ Laughter ]
Something like that.
-Yeah, or like axle grease
a little bit?
-Yes, grease.
Yes, it tastes like a grease,
a salty grease.
-The key is butter. Butter.
-Ah. Wait, butter first.
Then Vegemite.
-Yeah, just a lot of butter
and very little --
I don't know how Hugh
made it for you.
-Very little.
-But for me, that is --
Yeah, very little
of the actual Vegemite
and just a lot of butter.
-Can I -- Is it good for you?
It sounds like
it should be good for you.
-It's, uh --
It's not, not good for you.
-[ Laughs ] That's their slogan?
"It's not, not good for you."
-Exactly.
-I want to ask you a question.
I saw this beautiful photo of
your living room, of your home.
And --
-Aww. I haven't been there
for so long.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh, there it is.
-Now, here -- Can we just
zoom in for a second?
Is that a cardboard cutout
of Rod Stewart?
-Yeah. How fabulous is he?
Look at that.
-No, he's the coolest. But --
Is that real? What's happening?
Why is Rod Stewart
in your house?
Are you a big Rod Stewart fan?
-Yeah.
Not -- I mean --
Well, he --
It's quite --
So, what happened was --
-"So what had happened was --"
-He's -- Look, he's
part of the family now.
The kids refer to him
as like Uncle Rod,
Roddy Rod Stewart.
He's always there.
-He's Rod the mod, man.
He's cool.
But why is he
in your living room?
-Well, so,
Bobby did this show, "Vinyl"
where he played
a record executive.
And so he had this,
you know, fancy office
with, you know,
all the rock stars.
And, you know, so he had this
massive cutout of Rod Stewart.
And we brought it back
kind of as a joke,
and then it's become
part of the family,
part of the home.
-I want to talk about
some of your projects,
if you don't mind.
"Peter Rabbit 2"
is out this weekend.
That's going to be big
for the kids.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Really fun.
-It's fantastic.
And then kind of the opposite,
that I would say is probably
not for kids is "Physical,"
which I love.
It's set in the '80s.
You're very '80s in this.
It is well done,
whoever did the sets,
and the wardrobe,
by the way, is fantastic.
Can you set up what the show
is about for everyone?
-Yeah. I play Sheila Rubin.
She's kind of a very --
We meet her at a breaking point.
She's in
a dysfunctional marriage
and harboring, like,
a dark secret.
And she discovers aerobics
and kind of finds a way
out of her situation
and becomes kind of empowered,
uses her like, you know --
her illness for good.
And, yeah, it's set right at
that turning point of the '80s
where it's still
kind of the '70s,
and then, like, the world of,
like, home video is coming up
and the mall,
and, like, Ronald Reagan's
just been elected president.
So it sort of straddles
two worlds,
very much like Sheila,
like, in her head
and then how she appears.
So, it's a lot of fun
and very --
a really complicated character.
And yeah, I'm excited
for people to see it.
-It's on Apple TV Plus,
and you're fantastic
in everything you do.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Rose Byrne in "Physical."
Take a look.
-[ Laughs ] Are you okay?
-Hi! Oh, yes.
[ Chuckling ] I'm sorry --
I-I just didn't get enough --
-Breakfast.
-Sleep.
-No. Anyway,
so, when Ernie told me
that Danny was asking about
support, I was so excited.
Um --
-Who's Ernie?
-My husband.
-Oh, yes.
-He's chairman
of the San Diego Civics Club,
and they pretty much decide
who is and isn't getting
campaign support.
I thought I told you this.
No, I know I did, yeah.
-Yes. Yes, yes, yes --
No, of course.
-Yeah, but, yeah,
you weren't listening to me,
'cause I'm a boring,
fat housewife who's like --
-No. No, no, don't say that.
You look great.
-Oh, thank you.
It's a new dress.
-[ Thinking ] That's exactly
who she is. Fat, boring.
Who would listen to her?
Who would want to --
Her. That's where you're headed.
That's where you'll end up.
I'm so sorry, I have to go.
-I mean, that's --
Come on.
Rose Byrne, everybody.
"Physical" will be streaming
on Apple TV Plus
beginning June 18th.